hello
today i will talk about the pi dat
project which aims to compile
python and scientific python packages to
web assembly so it can be run inside a
browser
a few words about myself so i'm a data
scientist in paris
mostly working as an inventor consultant
and i'm also a core developer
at the psychic learn and the iodine
projects
so the plan today is that we'll um
we'll start by introducing pi diet and
discuss the features
we'll then look through different user
interfaces there are that are
available for biodiet and we'll also
discuss
the implications of running python on
the front end
then we'll consider the use case of
deploying
machine learning models with iodide
and we'll conclude finally with looking
at the current challenges and uh things
that still
are planned um to be developed in the
near future
so first what what is what is um
webassembly
so webassembly is a binary instruction
format for a virtual machine
initially it was developed to run inside
browsers but lately you can
essentially run it in in different
environments so you just take this
webassembly file you can run
it with a proper executioner
anywhere so it features it's it's
portable so it it
it doesn't change depending on the
architecture um
it provides neural native performance
and it is sandbox
same as javascript execution inside the
browser
so a typical build pipeline for
webassembly is as follows
we take some c plus files we will
compile them
using the m script in tool chain this
produces
webassembly modules and then we we add
some javascript glue code to load those
modules on
a html page and then finally we can
render them
in a browser
so since the python interpreter is um
is essentially written in c we can do
the same thing for the python
interpreter
and that's what the pie diet project
does
so we take the c python 3.8 we build it
for web assembly
and then now we are able to run python
code in
inside the browser so additionally um
other important parts of pyrite is that
we build
scientific like the main scientific
python packages uh here
there's a few but the full list will be
shown on the following slide
um so once we have those packages in
webassembly we can we can use them in
from from inside the browser other
important
modules are the micro pip package
which allows you to install pre-python
wheels from pipe pipe
and there is some interface that allows
you to do type conversion between python
and javascript so
meaning that if you have an object in
python you can expose it in javascript
and use it from javascript and the other
way around
of course building uh well trying to run
python in the browser is not
piedite is not the first project to do
that there have been a number of other
open source projects
so for instance we can mention pi by.gs
which builds
by byte using ismgs which is a
technology that that was before web
assembly
um and here it's for python 2. so
this project is no longer maintained um
then there is the briton project
which builds will reimplements
python3 interpreter using javascript
and it also includes parts of the sdlib
there the challenge is how can we
make um add support for for
modules that did use the extensions
there's also the the rust python project
which implements the
item three interpreter with rust and
because rust has really nice
tools to to produce webassemble you
essentially can easily
also build this for web assembly
there's also the micropython ports wasp
project which is a
project to compile micro python to
webassembly
this is fairly experimental but it's
targeted to low
low lower source environments or if you
want to download size to be very
reduced
um so if you look at the supported
python packages uh in pilot currently
that
focusing on those that require c that
have c extensions
it lists here so we we build the the
main uh like the core packages uh
including mumbai pandas
lib those are very reliable and we
mostly like we pass a good good part of
the test suite for
those packages so it means that we can
also run pi tests inside the
pilot then there are there is side by
side by is a
really large package which is a lot of
things and in
in addition it has a fortran and the
issue is that there is no
currently a compiler that can produce
webassembly for fortran so what we do is
we convert
that fortune for c to c uh but then this
works
to some extent but not for all modules
so so sci-fi is partially packaged let's
say
and then there is also the challenge of
linking blas and lapack libraries
into segment which is also something
that's still kind of ongoing
so so safe is fairly experimental and
as a result packages that depend on
senpai are also experimental even
although by this themselves they they
build fine
because they rely on safe i you know
they
they can run into age cases when things
don't work so those are psychic learners
that's model and second image hopefully
soon
and of course additionally you can
install um
power by pure python wheels from
pipeline
using micropip so
so micropip is just a small python
package that that
uses web apis to download packages from
some locations so it could be an ip or
some arbitrary location
it has a very rudimentary dependency
resolution
and just a reminder so if you if on the
right you can see that
how to determine if a wheel uh on pipe
is a pure python wheel or or
architecture specific uh wheel so for
instance here we have
on the first is the pure wheel which has
none any architecture
and the one below is a manual linux one
wheel so it it only runs in linux
and on a specific architecture so those
will not work
by that
uh then of course um this is the idea
okay so the ideal case is just install
things from pipe
uh piping however in reality there's
uh there's some modules that it doesn't
support so for instance there's also
processing super processing
or sockets so if those are imported at
the top level
um it'll fail so it means that they have
to be patched so packages have to be
patched sometimes
and in in which case you have to
actually submit it
as part of the pidei build system that
applies to patches and distributes and
the files um so for c extensions we
don't really have much choice we just uh
include them in the python build system
and we have to write
essentially a configuration file build
configuration file similar to that
what you will do for condo forge
and then finally those packages build so
we have a js file and data file those
are distributed via
vr our specific channel and
and you can load them either with load
package or micro
so an interesting thing is uh that we we
are able to convert types between
python and javascript so meaning that if
you have for instance in a
float in python and you want to pass it
to javascript it will be converted as a
number
um or for instance for strings so so for
for basic
sample types where we can we are able to
do this conversion for more complex
types or like
objects um we use either
proxy objects or extension types which
uh
essentially allow you to expose some
opaque wrapper that supports the number
of operators so for instance
you can you can set attributes get
attributes and
like the full list is uh provided in the
documentation
so to to give a more concrete example
for instance if you want to use
javascript from python
um you can essentially uh you have this
gs
model in python from which you can
import uh
js objects and including uh
access dom so for instance here we we
import the js package
module and then we we set the document
title to
to a new value so this means that this
python string is going to be converted
to a
to javascript and then we use this proxy
object to set the title
similarly from when you use python from
javascript there is this um biodivert
functionality where you can import
objects from the from the
global scope so for instance in this
case we have
we have moved well imported by imported
the sys module in javascript and then
now in javascript you can
call some attributes of this object
so in terms of performance what what do
we have uh
so here you have a list of uh benchmarks
like fairly simple benchmarks um that
compared the native performance with the
performance in
uh once the you build uh build the
package in
well once you build python for by that
for two different browsers so chrome and
firefox and
uh so on the x-axis you have the slow
down factor so one is
native performance and you can see that
the slow down factor is between one and
uh
ten let's say um and generally what we
see is that for
pure python uh benchmarks we are
four to eight times slower while for um
see
uh packages that or benchmarks that rely
strongly on c extensions
so for instance uh those that use a lot
of numpy operations
uh we are like one to two times slower
it should be noted also that there have
been a lot of
improvement in performance for instance
in chrome lately last
last year or so previously was almost
twice as
low so so there's still potential to
optimize this there's still potential to
make things faster by using the latest
version of
m scripts and tool chain etc
so now let's discuss user interfaces
so pi that can be used in a number of
ways
so the simplest one is just to use the
like the very simple
javascript console that's included in pi
died so it allows you to
you know type some comments uh get
results and also
expose those to javascript and you know
in this version
um so this is pretty sufficient for
very very simple prototyping however if
you want to do more more complex things
uh there is at the iolite project so the
iot project is uh
is essentially the project that started
in mozilla and that
that led to the creation pilot so
piodite initially was a
was a language plug-in for iodide and
iodide is a
is a interactive
scientific computing environment where
you can write uh
interactive documents and uh and publish
them and share them in a in a
user-friendly way so for instance here
you have some some animations where you
have a panel of deck
of a type of code and a tab of
descriptions and then you can generate
interactive figures and then you can
share them
so this project you the link is provided
you can
don't hesitate to try it out
unfortunately it's a bit less maintained
lately
if you go to other available projects
there is the boston project which is
fairly new
and what it does is it
it's essentially a jupiter notebook
version
that only uses static files so you don't
you don't have to run a back-end server
so the this is a fairly recent project
so for now it's only in french but
translation will happen soon likely now
let's consider in general what does it
mean to
to use uh to use biodiet in all those
user interfaces or
generally in python apps than run inside
the browser
so in the classical classical setup you
have
you have essentially your browser that
has a user interface
the user interacts with it and then
requests
are sent to the server and which in
turns
make calculations in some kernel and
then if you need data
data is queried locally and server in
this
setup where you have a python running in
the browser
well then you you can move calculations
into the browser right so your kernel is
inside the browser now
and then you would only make um
make a request to the data when needed
so what what does it imply well first in
terms of usability
it doesn't really change much so you
have either way you can
run uh you can just go to a web page as
a user and you'll see
calculations done you don't have to
install anything uh you just
have to open a web page what what what
really changes is scalability so now
because we
only serve static files so you only need
to serve
by date packages you don't need to run
calculations on the subserver
you can really scale a lot so and easily
so you don't have to maintain an
expensive and
like complex infrastructure
server infrastructure to serve all those
users you just have to serve static
files
so for instance uh currently uh biodiet
has around
50 to 80 000 downloads per month and
so potentially there is like a few
tens of thousands users uh potential new
users
each month and if we wanted to
serve those users uh to to make them use
um with the server-based uh
architecture that would be difficult so
for instance um
the binder project uh allows you to run
um
you know to run jupyter instances and
and scale scale them to a large number
of users and it's it's a fairly complex
and and
successful and challenging project so uh
of course you can do much more in but in
binder that what you would be able to do
with iodide because it's uh
it's more let's say less experimental
but
but the idea is that with iodide
essentially you can you can just
transfer static files and
that scales extremely well so what
should be also noted is that
packages are downloaded once and then
they are cached in the browser so this
is also good for privacy because
uh well you don't you don't make too
much remote requests and also
uh generally while calculations are run
locally so you don't need to send your
data or at least not as much data to the
remote server
a last point which is important is that
uh in the in the case of algorithms
or like some scientific code
well the python app in the browser would
be just some archive of
python files and uh maybe some python
objects
and so this you can you can easily
examine this on the client side so if
you if you go to a
website that uses such an app you can
just examine what's happening whether
it's a code used etc
and so this is uh this is good for
transparency but
in other use cases that can be also a
bit problematic if you want to
you know protect your private
information
or like some some knowledge about what
is done in the code etc
so let's now look at the use case of uh
deploying
machine learning models uh in general
so in general the classical workflow is
as follows
we train some model on the machine
then we serialize it to disk so then
depending on the framework you would
have
i don't know for instance for psychic
learning you would probably use pickle
or
on an x for um you know tensorflow you
would use this
judicious format for python torch
another one etc so
um then you have to develop some kind of
web service to uh so that the user can
interact with your model
then you package that in a container
probably doctor
and then you deploy it on the server so
of course the last three steps are
automated by some tools so or at least
obstructed by some tools
but they're still there so it's still
something that has to happen in some way
um so an interesting part is that
um if you look at
some in in the machine learning
ecosystem there have been lately some
developments of tools that try to
improve uh the model inference so for
instance you have the onyx project
which is a standard format for for
machine learning models
um and it you have also the inference
engines that allow you to
to run predictions given this uh the
standard form so
so for instance you can take a side
guitar model put it into onyx and then
you know deploy it and you can also
have people have managed to also compile
for instance onyx to webassembly so
it means that potentially this model you
will be able to run it in the browser
uh without having to actually use python
so this is good in terms of because it's
optimized it's fast the model is small
but the disadvantage is it's restricted
to the predefined operators you have so
it's
restricted to the to the operators that
are defined in onyx or
that are defined in tensorflow and
if you have some custom pre-processing
steps well that can be promoting
so um a side note if you look at
the current usage of uh what
serialization formats are you used for
instance for cyclic learn
uh it turns out that most people seem to
use pickle
so the question is can we just use
pickle with pilot and
uh like deploy models in
in the in the browser so um
so essentially pickle is uh has some
several issues so it's unsafe it's very
brittle to environment changes so if you
change
uh your version of uh of your
dependencies or the version of python
you the model that you severalized
before will likely not work
but the advantage is it's portable and
it's uh it's not a pack so it means that
you can always always recover your
uh the python object you serialize and
like looking look into what elements
so then in pioneer because it's just
essentially python running uh
in the browser what the the steps to
serialize
to deploy a model is very are fairly
straightforward so you just
first have to train this model in the
same environment
with the same version of python and
dependencies as biodiet
so then you serialize the model with
pickle
so you get a byte object
you send this byte object to to your
browser so you just load it in the
browser and then you just severalize it
there
and essentially here now you have the
same model that's runs in python
and then you can run inference for
instance changes
so generally generally this works um
however this is still fairly
experimental
uh because uh mainly of the site by
packaging so sapi is currently blocker
so some things inside of them will also
not work and then
you know the download size is uh is
relatively large
but but the idea is is fully acceptable
uh to go one step
more you can even because you have the
full model you can even uh
tune it or drain it in in your browser
so um so imagine you have
you you have some use cases where you
accumulate data that you that's your
personal data
in this case you don't even have to
share it with some server so the model
they can they're trained you can just
uh try to tune the model locally
um so the advantage is of course it's
privacy privacy preserving
you can fully control what's what's
what's the thing you're optimizing
though of course the model evaluation is
a bit more challenging so to give a
computer example for instance uh
i don't know how many of you search for
simple python
functions in some search engines and you
get
some results like this so you get a lot
of tutorials
um and then you have python two
documentation and then maybe somewhere
at the bottom you have python three
documentation from the standard library
so the thing is clearly like at least in
my case i would like to see that as a
first item
um but apparently the personalized
search
system doesn't doesn't manage to
determine that so what you could imagine
is some
summary ranking model on top of uh like
your top
20 results that will be updated as you
browse and then you know that will
score some domains higher than other
ones so if
this is a like a side project idea if
somebody wants to look into it
that that that's i think it's nice of
you
um well
so so we have seen some of the things
you can do with biodiet
now there are still remaining challenges
so one challenge is the download size
so essentially a python ecosystem was
never optimized for size
and as a result you can well for one
have very large packages such as scipy
even if you use just one tiny part of
sci-fi for instance sparse mattresses
you still have to load everything else
and this is problematic in terms of uh
you know if terms of download size if
you just go to a web page it downloads
stuff you don't actually use then there
is
for instance the inclusion of tests in
the in the main package so
which is nice is uh for development but
then if you use this
package you don't necessarily need tests
when you deploy
the deploy it somewhere
and then there is of course if you want
to do static analysis of imports it's
also kind of challenging because there
is like
uh lots of important needs that no not
all of them are used and then you have
you can have conditional imports and
then if
the conditional parts fail something
else happens so it's it's it's
challenging
problem so the bottom line is currently
uh
the minimum size uh to run
iodide is around 20 megabytes uh when
you download that
with compression because browsers now
implement compression
um that's transparent kind of to the
user
you get around eight megabytes so this
is the minimum download size you have to
to to run pi diet on some webpage and
then
of course each package you use
additionally adds additional space so
for instance pandas
uses uh requires more eight more
megabytes to download
but still there is there is a lot there
is some potential to optimize this
download size so this is something
that's just
requires time to to tune
another thing is there's clearly
limitations
due to the environment where you run
python
so for instance there are some
limitations that are inherent to the
wasm
uh virtual machine so for instance the
fact that you cannot do super processes
um well
initially you couldn't do treading now
you can but we still haven't enabled it
in bio that
there are no sockets uh
it's also a 32-bit architecture while i
think
right now most python packages and
scientific community optimize more for
64-bit
um and then not all system calls are
implemented so it means that
um you can you can in some edge cases
you can end up with a system call that's
uh
like for system calls for instance
interaction with the file system or
interaction with
the kernel in some other way that's just
not implemented and not doing what it
should be doing
it's fairly rare but it happens um and
then there is
the fact that if you want to interact
javascript javascript has other some
specifics so for instance has no
interviewer type so
it only has a number type which is the
same kind of similar as a float
or or a big integer type so you have to
make a decision how to make a conversion
uh there is no standard way to represent
n dimensional arrays
um you can also end up with something
that's
um essentially a valid method name in
javascript but not a valid method name
in python for instance finally
uh is like using a finally somewhere in
the in python code where this is a
syntax error
and to conclude uh there's still a lot
of
things that could be improved so for
instance uh we we
need to work on keeping up with
inscription releases because those
releases include a lot of
fixes both in terms of size in terms of
performance
and just bug fixes we also need to
spend time on upstream patches so
currently the packages are built
sometimes there are patches to
to make them work with biodiet and not
all of those packaged
patches are sent downstream currently um
there is also
maybe a need to implement some small
parts of the
stdlib for instance those that rely on
threads
and they're frequently used so you
cannot use for instance download
use the http client currently because it
requires
sockets but you can rewrite it with the
web api
there is a challenge of how we deal with
dynamic ranking of
lapak and blas and which in turn would
hopefully improve
the situation with sci-fi um there is
also
the question of general sustainability
of the of the build system because as
you
well currently all those builds are
running the same ci and as you add more
packages the ci gets a bit slower so
it's it's getting a bit more
harder to contribute so there's uh
open questions how to deal with that
maybe
you know go more more towards the kind
of forge model or try to
integrate into quarter fours etc uh
there's also trading which is currently
disabled but uh we'll we
should be possible to enable it and
we're waiting for a wider
browser adoption so in general if you
want to what you're interested in
contributing uh
don't hesitate there have there's a lot
of things that could be improved and
we're
we really welcome both technical and
non-technical computers
finally i would like to to thank uh the
team who
started the iodide and uh and the
piedite project at mozilla
uh other iodide contributors and uh
developers
um the nextedi company whose open source
development company in france who funded
my work on pie diet
last uh one year ago
and i'd like to thank boston project who
is developing
who's working doing nice development
work in on the user interface uh with
the pi data
so thank you if you have uh any
questions please check the
pi data schedule for for to know
when the question sessions happen thank
you